i know there are dudes married with kids
taking pictures shirtless with their abs
so this goes both ways but if you want
to see who's married to a piece of [ __ ]
dude
just go look at what people are
posting to themselves the person that's
showing you do the 20 push-ups and then
they get up out of breath like
another day
no getting out working
in everybody go out there and get it in
they act like they're trying to inspire
you it's like dude it's still about you
take the vanity shot and then writes a
bunch of just spiritual [ __ ] underneath
it are you a wolf or is because a wolf
does something
that's a dummy [ __ ] warriors don't need
sleep
five o'clock in the morning
when someone comes up to you
and they shake your hand and they look
away that lets you know
that they're trying to [ __ ] get into
your fortress